[Music]
comedy's can sometimes like surprise you
with what's going on these Danes with
the kids and what they're up to and I'm
watching the movie and the first scene
really kind of threw me for a loop
instantly again I'm a little repressed
but why don't you tell us what happens
in that first scene I apologize so in
the in the opening scene
I am pleasuring myself to a VHS tape
it's not me it's a character it's not me
myself it is the bidding just catchment
a pit is the character hope and Gregory
who is a gymnast and she's pleasuring
herself to a VHS tape of her triumphant
moment winning the bronze medal okay
okay it is really funny but here's my
question
alright and I this is what I always
think about because I'm a repressed
Catholic but I always think okay did you
have to like see that or prepare your
parents for that scene when they when
they were gonna watch the movie that's
just what I always think about yes
so I totally warn them before and
there's also a big gymnastic sex scene
in the movie as well which I prepared
them for you want to see that in
theaters you need to see that big yeah
take it possible yeah um so I warned
them but they came with me to the
premiere last week and where my mother
didn't know it started the movie so
she's really excited and she kept
holding my hand and I knew this
masturbation moment was coming up we
can't be holding hands for this I pull
my hand away from mother and she just
kept on grabbing it not not for not for
this not for this not because she
doesn't know she doesn't know what's
happening and then what about these
sexual gymnastics scene oh yeah so
there's this big sexual gymnastics team
and my parents were they kept on trying
to overcompensate that they were like
cool with it so there was like a lot of
laughter at weird and weird moment
and I like to looking around to just
make sure everyone knows they're fine
with everything great
now was there anything that went over
their parents heads like they didn't
understand there was some of the
terminology they didn't fully get so we
actually took them to see the trailer
around Thanksgiving to us you and your
host right this is my husband I hear
co-wrote the movie with me and we went
to see the trailer at the movies and
there's this part in the trailer where I
have this little speech about a taint
locket and after the after they know how
one does what happened conversations
from time to time yeah so after the
movie my mom said so you said um you
said hey hey hey hey hey
it's at I was giving her like a tank
tutorial yes so the area yes it's this
air I said much familiar with what that
is so that my father's standing behind
her looking up on his phone he's like
the Urban Dictionary says that the taint
is the area in between your front hole
and and then so once I told them that
then they started to try and use it just
in everyday
they're trying to be supported at swear
our parents are different I would be
like no and then you'd never hear it
about again so what kind a Rosie I think
they were trying to show their support
but it was Thanksgiving sometimes like
we need to stop the turkeys tank well
you do you know yeah
you